👏
👏Meme👏review👏
👏Say it👏aah
Why did I do that?
Meme review
YouTube's
favorite
show
YouTube's
favorite
show
everyone
Say it with me: "Youtube favorite show everyone," say it with me
I am so excited. Guess why, because this week's we have a lot of plentiful memes. Oh boy
I'm excited. Let's begin meme number one
👏
👏👏
JK Rowling she's back at it again
Remember when JK Rowling went out and said "Oh, Hermione she can be black, it's canon totally!
White skin was never specified. I am such a progressive person."
I thought about this
literally years ago before it was popular to be an annoying
Verified Twatter on Twitter and then people pointed out. Wait a minute JK Rowling
It says right here Hermione has a white face, you even wrote it yourself
I mean JK Rowling has already been made fun of for this
No one:
JK Rowling
Dobby had a 10 inch cock. Remember that, everyone?
Well she went out again JK Rowling and said that Dumbledore and
Grindelwald had an intense
sexual relationship
JK Rowling reappearing
Every two months to say something literally no one asked about is me adding more random details to my essay to up my word count
Listen, it would be fine if the characters were like this originally
But it seems like you're changing them after the fact so you could see more inclusive and get good press
Okay, I'm sorry I'll stop
Okay, thank you
Wait, just one more thing
What is it?
Guess um guess which character is actually gay
What?
I said guess which character is actually gay.
I don't know
All of them
*poods skratta*
JK Rowling confirms that Dumbledore had long ewww
JK, please, no one asked
JK Rowling reveals Dumbledore a gay
JK Rowling reveals Dumbledore and Grindelwald had incredibly intense sexual relationship
or
JK Rowling reveals your mother is a homosexual
JK Rowling confirms that the readers were gay all along
Joke's on you. I never read Harry Potter because I'm not gay. I do like dick though.
JK looks up fan fiction about Dumbledore and Ron having unprotected sex while Dobby is watching
JK Rowling: My goodness, what a great idea. Why did I not think of that?
At this point
Yeah, this seems like she's just a fanfiction writer at this point. I mean it worked for Fifty Shades of Grey
It's literally a Twilight fan fiction. Even Elon Musk himself confirms
JK Rowling is gay. Now we know everyone which Harry Potter character is gay Harry Ron Hermione
LMAO all of them
ALL OF THEM ARE GAY
Nobody JK Rowling the following wizards like fisting Jesus Christ stop
She's like George Lucas and Steven Spielberg
Editing their own old classics. They just can't keep their hands out of it JK Rowling
After accidentally stumbling onto a Harry Potter furry fanfiction write that down
JK Rowling when she announces the characters in Harry Potter are gay after
20 years of existing as well as there being evidence of characters are straight.
I gotta be honest with you guys, I'm kinda retarded
How does he have that voice?
JK Rowling reveals that Hagrid was black all along
How could we uh, miss the Sun sure integral part of the story?
You're a wizard mother why it was played by samuel l.jackson all along now. I'm gay and I agree with that
Don't be fake and with the moon landing Thank You. JK Rowling, thank you.
Harry Potter characters
JK Rowling
JK Rowling: hErMiOnE iS bLaCk.
Also JK Rowling: her white face, though
Characters from Harry Potter clearly isn't gay in any book that they're in
JK Rowling: reality can be whatever I want
All right, we get it Felix. There's an abundance of JK Rowling memes.
I'm sorry. I just like it okay? This meme's
👏
👏👏
will get the seven point gay
Good joke Felix. Thank you
Next👏meme👏
also related to someone making ermm
Alright, let's just read what shane dawson tweeted.
I didn't 🐱  my cat
I didn't c🐱 on cat
I didn't put my peepee anywhere near my cat
I've never done anything weird with my cat
I promised myself I wouldn't go in to make an apology videos at the last year's thing
So I'm just trying to be as short and honest with this as possible.
Thank you👏for your honesty Shane Dawson
A guide to YouTube star Shane Dawson's viral apology about his cat
This is why I tell you guys if you need help writing your apologies
just let your boy know cuz you might end up like
I mean this apology is 10 out of 10. I don't know
What in the world
So what happened was basically Shane on a podcast
said that he came on his cat and he sounds pretty
Sincere when he says it
But I used to watch him Dawson like way back in the day and I know he had with like really edgy and strange sense
Of humor it was always really overly sexual and I always thought it as a way of Shane
Dealing with his own sexual frustrations. He hadn't come out as bisexual yet. So in retrospect it actually makes a lot of sense
So while a lot of people might be shocked by this it's obviously just Shane
making a joke, but the fact that he says it in such a
Serious tone. I also understand why some people think it's real. Although it's clearly not real
Okay, but the most important thing out of all this is of course. Yes
That's right. Everybody the memes
I mean this just brings whole new meaning to sad cat memes. I can't look at them the same way
I just know Shane did something bad to *skratta*. Sorry cat. What did Shane do to you?
Ah, oh, they're so sad and cute Shane hurt you
didn't he just point out the GFuel way to chain touch you the only reason I'm bringing this up is to deflect from
This story that I brought up on a podcast
And I thought it was hilarious like but apparently he was more like shocked by it
so the day at like he went to tell everyone in school that I didn't masturbate in my cat and I'm like
That's not what I did, but then I realized that first of all, all right
Let me just say guys in case you're listening to this podcast footage in your website and you're hurt
Which honestly you should be
Just know that I didn't f🐱 my cat
I didn't come on my cat
I didn't put my dick anywhere near my cat
I never done anything weird with my cat, and I promised myself. I wasn't going to
Thank you Shane Dawson, just for making that easier for me.
Why did both me and Shane have the same history?
Listen you I literally just had to rub my cat's belly and his dick would flop up and I was a kid and I thought
That was funny. All right, stop it, please Wall Street Journal Vox News please
Shane Dawson's cat tomorrow on Good Morning America those poor kitty know everyone bangs his pants me
No way. Come on. I can't believe everything you hear. Oh, yeah daddy likes
Okay. All right. Let's move on Shane Dawson. I'm warning Sheen does his cat. She says Christ I oh god
Absolutely. No one Shane Dawson Jess. I
Think we need Shane a meme review at this point. Oh my god everyone 3-chain. Damn
I thought he'd ask you skank Shane Dawson. He said yes. Okay. Now you've gone too far
Chucky cheese when they find out Shane Dawson was effing his kin Chuckie Cheese. I bet they're the ones that discovered this
the Shane Dawson meme gets a
7-point gay cats, by the way, the cat is gay. I feel bad
Like honestly a lot of people are memeing this but a lot of people are actually taking this very seriously
And are actually mad at Shane Dawson and going after Shane Dawson and attacking him just for this
you know in a way I can really relate to him because you know
He had an edgy past that obviously follows him around and it's not who who he is anymore
So I can relate and I feel bad
So it'd be nice and support Shane everyone and also Shane
Happy marriage, is that what you say? Happy marriage?
👏Next👏meme
Deaf people. That's right, everyone
The internet has discovered that deaf people exist
They do in fact exist
you know when you watch something on
flicks and then the subtitles just shows up being like noise in the background like an audible sound or like
[cOUghs IN SWedIsH]
Music playing. Well that's become a meme now subtitles
Music deaf people it's there has to be an old name. This cannot be
Subtitles outside sounds deaf people Wow, I can truly experience this
Thank you subtitles and Netflix. Thank you so much. I was wondering like how did they react to that? They're like, um
Okay. Now this is no weighing shape or form making fun of bad people. Of course
I just want to make that clear before box rights or not an article. This is just a way to acknowledge and
Understand them trying to learn each other trying to make a place better world
Subtitles cool jazz music that's people. I wonder if it does it say that in spider-man. That would make me happy subtitles
Scary sound deaf people Felix. Now you stepping a little too far on the toes here
Okay, but let me just ask one simple question what language do deaf people?
Thinking they never heard language
Then how do they think a very philosophical meme indeed?
captions
Yes, when the deaf person asks you what time it is but you don't understand sign where's language and it's
8:54 so you have to improvise
that relatable moment when it's
5:23 and you don't know the time. Okay. Alright, I'm sorry for being insensitive. I had gomennasai
alright sumimasen
But let me ask you another question if a deaf person
Goes to court it is still called a hearing
Top five comments do I have the green screen on what the hell? Why is it on? Ah
deaf people exist reddit right now
I mean, I think that summarizes it pretty well this meme gets a gay deaf person. I don't know
Last meme, that's right. We have time for one more meme everyone. Hope you guys are excited about this one
It's gonna be very epic. Now. This Ralph meme has become popular and thank God
I'm not supposed to give my opinion, but thank God. I really wanted another cartoon meme Family Guy
Simpson Spongebob
There's just not enough cartoon names Ralph can't be in another meme his last one
Got too popular Ralph Ralph, please World War 1 soldiers in
1918 we survived the Great War Spanish flu just came out of nowhere
Mediocre action movie director. I don't really like this me mediocre action movie director
We need an actor to play the main Cara main Joel son. Dwayne the rock
Johnson I can appreciate this one of these lava exists your dog. No
Okay, that's good whatever I start my PC
Yeah
Why does Skype keep thing existing Jesus in Christ and discord don't even get me started a finished
Program. I don't know why it happened. I cannot launch discord unless it launches itself at startup
So if I close it and then try to launch it again
It doesn't work and I can't even uninstall it and stay if I want to play games team
I'll just start you when I dig straight down in Minecraft. Oh god
I know the feeling small game developer stars relatively successful game. Seriously. Eh
Quentin tarantino's so i'm making this new movie white actors who want to say they okay. Alright, okay
okay, one more you kids gets one more famous pulls down pants to take a sh
ant-man
👏
👏👏
I rate this meme a four gay Ralphs. Thank you guys for watching another episode of meme review
👏
👏blue shirt kid
will he host meme review the real question that everyone asks at the beginning of this video now smash like if you want
Blue shirt kid to host meme review and I will see what I can do. All right, but for now
*Felix descending into the abyss because TSeries is passing him*
What [insert irrelevant game name]
becoming relevant
No, no, don't leave
No, please sponsor eagle. Please do something
Yes, yeah
This game is still relevant God DAMNIT!!